انت جارب يعني انا مريت فيها كل ما بصير
معي زي هيك بحل لزوجتي اكتر
والعلاقه بتقدر
فطور بالعلاقه
تملي بتزهقي وهو بيمل بزهق لما تبعدي
بتحاسبي يعني حاله بتراجعي شو انا كنت
غلطانه بايش كنت مقصره وبتحاولي انك
تجديدي
[موسيقى]
يعني انا مع هاي الدراسه ومع هذه الابحاث
لانه عن تجربه بحكي انه مرات انا ممكن
بسافر لحالي هيك بضيف فتره عن زوجي وحتى
هو لما يغيب حتى لما يغيب بالشغل انا بكون
يعني مشاعري وهو مثلا بعيد عني بحس
باشتياق شويه لو كل فتره فعلا بعمل اشتياق
وبيعمل سعاده اكثر ما يضل بوجهه بعض اكيد
يعني
نعم انا باكد على هذا الحكي يعني تجربه
بحكي لك ههه
[موسيقى]
فكره كلها غلط صحيح
اذا ما كانش الزوجين مع بعض دائما يكونوا
مع بعض ما بتضبط الحياه
اصلا الحياه
البعد جفى
[موسيقى]